jonathan poursuit cette édition cette
édition du 7 8 consacré aux journées du
patrimoine on change complètement le
sujet et oui je vous propose de
découvrir un lieu atypique qui se trouve
à montesson il s'agit d'une
champignonnière c'est là qu'on cultive
les champignons va découvrir allait à la
rencontre d'un jardinier de nuit vous
allez voir il s'appelle angèle moioli
c'est un homme passionné et passionnant
on les appelle les jardiniers de la nuit
ces hommes comme angèle moioli faut
pousser les champignons de paris sous
terre aujourd'hui seulement 3
champignonnistes exercent dans les
yvelines un métier en perdition dont a
hérité angèle moioli je suis né dans les
champignons ma famille mon grand-père
était championne is mais pas en chantier
risque donc c'est vrai dans le
champignon j'ai toujours voulu sa
maison aussi toute la famille un savoir
transmis de génération en génération
qu'angel moioli souhaite partager avec
le public lors des journées du
patrimoine
c'est le patrimoine de la région
parisienne champion de paris comme on
dit champion de paris cette date près de
ferrières paris c'est ici la région ile
de france c'est le début du championnat
ici
est sur ce plateau avant de parler de
ces champignons je vous présente déjà
mais ne lambert bonsoir auteur metteur
en scène comédien directeur de la
compagnie bulles de zinc vous
présenterai ce week end histoire du lieu
où comme employé le poisson spectacle à
saint quentin 15 et 16 septembre et bien
sûr notre autre invité annie gauthier
merci nous avons rejoint vous êtes
membre de l'association mémoire histoire
de montesson on parlera notamment de la
champignonnière en partant de ces
championnats vous attendez beaucoup de
monde pour les visités on a vu quelques
images ça intéresse beaucoup oui
beaucoup nous avons beaucoup d'eux parce
qu'on a demandé une inscription
préalable nous avons beaucoup de
personnes qui ont téléphoné qui ont
utilisé le courriel pour s'inscrire et
nous sommes contraints de refuser des
inscriptions
donc ça veut dire que c'est
complet oui c'est dommage mais on se
sera renouvelée éventuellement le stream
we made you lie le champignonnistes fait
des visites et des explications sur la
culture du champignon au fil de l'année
ça lui arrive pour la semaine du goût
les 20 et 21 octobre voilà la patronne
et donc vous allez assurer le début de
la visite en falloir pour la journée du
patrimoine
nous nous participons en tant qu' une
mémoire et histoire de montée sont donc
des associations d'histoire locale et
nous allons présenter la l'exploitation
des carrières dans toute la vallée de la
seine est un qui a un band calcaire le
calcaire a été exploitée pour les
constructions on avait besoin de pierre
évidemment donc on a exploité les
carrières et à montesson comme dans les
villes voisines il ya eu l'exploitation
des carrières localement pour les
églises de sa retrouver deux par exemple
et aussi pour paris quand osman a fait
son ménage à paris tous les immeubles
haussmanniens avait besoin de pierre
pour là pour être construits donc tout
ça ça donne une histoire une histoire
bien cachés puisqu'on est dans les
carrières et on a donc il va déranger
avoir un premier exposé fait par mémoire
et histoire de montesson où on va
présenter comment on extrait la pierre
la méthode et puis ensuite pourquoi on
va arrêter d'extraire de la pierre
puisque du calcaire y en a encore
pourquoi on arrête c'est parce qu'il y a
le béton qui va remplacer les pierres
début du 20e siècle 1920 1940 donc on
arrête et alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ces carrières bien là je peux
apporter une petite anecdote il ya la
grand-mère d'une
il ya la grand-mère dans la montée sonné
qui nous a rapporté la chose suivante un
jour sa grand mère a vu venir à la
maison à monsieur qui lui a demandé
d'acheter les trous les vides des
carrières à la écarquillaient les yeux
j'essaie d'y mais je suis quoi je suis
en face je suis comme une épicière la
laquelle un client vienne demander
d'acheter les trous de gruyère
et parce que je voulais en faire alors
de ces trous et bien ce qu'il voulait en
faire c'est le premier qui a commencé à
cultiver des champignons
autour de 1860 et celui ci le possible
du côté de bonté sont alors à monter son
oui voilà déjà reçu un maillot lille a
dû bouillir il est le dernier
champignonnistes à monter sans mes
reportages complets justement d'ailleurs
vous les avez visité ses caresses de
champignons reportage complet qui sera
donc à découvrir dans l'acte us et à
20h30 sur tv fils on va juste pour
conclure cette édition passer des
champignons poisson